upped his game in such a significant way
and improves what he's been doing on the
offensive side as you just see right
there
wild scene kevin durant pick up where he
left off
kyrie irving doing the same
triple from tyree irving and people have
throughout the course of his career this
isn't by accident that's not a fluke
shot with players that can move
a lot of use 12 guys on this roster 24
or younger is kyrie irving two for two
from long range
messy started the game shooting six for
eight from the floor
here's a rare appearance from kessler
edwards who checked in the ball game
during that free throw from kd
kyrie
gets it back three point in the corner
he's three for three from three
and just take a look at this play the
quickness of the hands get ahead
everyone's staying wide and push it and
then this is an excellent job here he
gets it that durant who just gives it
right back in the corner and they all
will and sometimes that is such a big
indicator for the magic of how they play
if they're knocking down those stretch
shots kyrie irving
even in the trees it's a high percentage
shot shooting the three well
[Applause]
kyrie irving squeezes it sets up the
offense
irving
working on carter jr swish
brooklyn shooting 71
from the floor blackstone wins the tip
irie irving good to see back on the
floor no issue with the hand as he
finishes off the window for the duke
10th season out of washington
oh you know he can heat up in a hurry
a microwave in his own ride kyrie irving
to give him
continuation
what a play from kyrie irving
well and look at this excellent screen
by claxton and then he just continues to
snake through
but he is up to 23
points
and back door cut there make it 25.
oh he's halfway to 50.
look at this beautiful pass by james
johnson on a dive up under that hang
time comes from
the strength of the core we see this
often from james johnson but
that's where i mean folds
four minutes gone by in the second
fourth
irving crossover inside left hand
a magic trick
timeout orlando
look at this smooth moves cut through
the defense oh what a finish
looking at the hand and kyrie is hitting
everything
than any other team in the association
and i think you add in their excitement
about the growth of wendell carter jr
what he looks like just tapping into his
potential oh the midi from kyrie irving
he's up to 31. from kyrie irving his
window carter jr can't get that to fall
rebound drummond but irving had 30
and a half as he pulled up again and
knocks down the three
kyrie irving
it's the efficiency that he's doing it
at
the ease i mean
uh
but it hasn't just been isolations
again
kashaf
in his 11-year nba career
again
are you kidding me
every sitter get in the show
2 24 to go in this first half
are you not entertained
irving is a little bit of a surprise
he now has 40 points in the first half
six of six from the line six of seven
from the three-point line
can't be 75 more talented players in the
league than kyrie irving
i think